mon
[Musique]
oh
ce qui est intéressant ce type de visite
c'est que l'on rend accessible le
monument un autre type de visiteurs ça
fait partie enfin inhérente de nos
métiers on met des médiateurs on est là
pour faciliter en fait
le lien entre le public et les monuments
et effectivement tous les publics sont
différents et a fortiori pour des
déficients visuels qui doivent se
déplacer si avec toutes les contraintes
d'accessibilité déjà et puis après
qu'ils ne peuvent pas voir cette
magnifique architecture
[Musique]
comprendre comment le tout s'articule
nous ça nous pousse à explorer d'autres
pistes à quelque chose
il arriva de matérialiser la signifiant
de là en fait donc il est de forme
octogonale
on sent la petite tour en saillie bas
sur le bâtiment françois 1er avant que
josé votre main la date
du vote envoie depuis comme ça le hand
n'a plus aucune fonction en fait on fait
travailler d'autres sens barre par le
toucher et puis après on comprend ce qui
se passe comment s'est fait aux
recherches enfin on essaie de comprendre
comment c'est fait mais par le biais du
du cerveau et nous de l'aider yeux on
est entre le premier et le deuxième
étage et au milieu en fait de la façade
d'un petit édifice architectural avec
des colonnes reis d'aidé traîne quand
jean de chaque côté donc deux colonnes
qui encadre en fait la france et puis
ensuite on appelle à fronton
triangulaire
savamment organisée là moi je suis
arrivé jusqu'à la seconde mais ça a été
très difficile parce qu'en fait je
retenais c'était qu'elle écoute
aux tables où je voyais rien et ça a été
très dur c'est pour ça que je me bats je
pense que je me suis battue à ce moment
là
encore pour arriver à faire quelque
chose mais maintenant c'est vrai que les
jeunes dès qu'ils ont un problème
de vue et où il ya tout un tas de
techniques technologie tout maintenant
jeudi
e
[Musique]
cette maquette elles étaient fabriqués
dès l'origine pour être utilisé avec des
déficients visuels donc c'est pour ça
qu'elle a été pensée avec différents
modules qui se détache
avec un certain niveau en fait de relief
et un travail au niveau des découpes des
fenêtres là pour château de louis xii
pour bien sentir la forme triangulaire
et pointue des câbles des lucarnes par
exemple ou l'escalier de pouvoir repérer
le fait qu'il ait en avant de la façade
qui lassé ouverture ce qu'elle a bien
ressenti d'ailleurs claudine donc tout a
été pensé il ya eu un gros travail en
amont quel effet
oui des bustes moi j'avais déjà et déjà
fait mais j'avais encore de la vision et
j'avais prêté - attention que là mais là
j'ai vraiment que toucher et on
s'aperçoit qu'on arrive à faire quand
même des choses à comprendre les choses
que vient qu'avec lui toucher
un boni de francs soit 1 qui avait
grandi oui avant la yellow et la fin
d'année
et puis une petite particule halte au
niveau du menton la
gt police non pas du tout
pourquoi il avait calmé les relais
aujourd'hui en fait c'est sa femme qui
fait ça ça barde à la
porte la barbe ça lui permettait de
cacher une cicatrice mais il faut faut
bouger il faut aller se battre pour
aller en fac
je me bats forcément pour moi mais pour
les autres parce que c'est vrai que
mes gros ça commence à bouger comme
enfin à bois surtout c'est vrai qu'on
écoutait
c'est pas facile tous les jours mais ces
hausses la savate c'est fait